more now on news breaking in the last
hour and there's been an explosion along
a gas pipeline in Lithuania which also
supplies neighboring Latvia let's bring
in our International Affairs editor
Dominic wagorn Dominic what uh what can
you tell us about this explosion
but we can say where it happened it
happened in Northern Lithuania and on a
gas pipeline that supplies that bit of
Lithuania so the northern part of the
country and Latvia as well so any
pipeline that's going to supply gas
between two countries you can assume is
going to be fairly substantial and from
some of the videos that we can't yet
verify but that we're seeing on social
media it does seem to have caused a
massive explosion According to some
reports an explosion that went 160 feet
up into the sky above where the
explosion went off so
um it appears to be some kind of device
or a terrible accident that ignited the
pipeline exploded it sufficiently to let
enough gas then escape to cause this
kind of Fireball that we're seeing
videos of and it seems to have been a
big enough fire to cause authorities to
as a precaution evacuate a large area
around the size of the explosion it's
near the town of pasvallis uh I don't
know if I'm pronouncing that right but
it's a town in northern Lithuania it's
got a population of around six and a
half thousand people so a reasonably
large Village or town that entire town
has been evacuated we're being told we
can't say what the cause is it's pretty
early in the day to say exactly what is
going on here what the what the likely
explanation for this explosion is but
you have to say the background to this
is that we've seen attacks on civilian
energy infrastructures both in Ukraine
because of the war there but also in
other parts of Russia for instance uh
well away actually from Ukraine from
Ukraine's borders we've seen oil
refineries oil Depots going up very
mysterious attacks there going up in
Flames one in urkutsk a few weeks ago
caused an explosion or a fire at least
that reportedly was a kilometer a square
kilometer in in size and surface area so
some very big explosions have been
happening happening mysteriously in
energy installations in Russia and now
possibly in Lithuania whether this is
related to the war or not it isn't clear
but it's certainly not something that
normally happens to pipelines without
some presumably fairly nefarious or
Sinister motivation behind it and of
course we also had an attack a sabotage
that's still unexplained on undersea
pipelines the the gas pipeline between
Russia and Germany the Nordstrom
pipeline was attacked causing a massive
explosion under the water there and a
loss of a lot of gas so there is there's
a lot of this that's been happening
related to the war in Ukraine and we're
now seeing I think the initial videos
coming from the scene of this attack on
this pipeline in Northern Lithuania as
you can see the entire Sky lit up with
orange light and orange Flames rising
from the site of that explosion in
Northern Lithuania I guess moral emerges
to the extent of the damage and the and
the disaster course to the area but also
hopefully more of an explanation as to
why this has happened
Dominic thanks so much